>>Narrator: The burgeoning
realm of games
and simulations has become
a billion-dollar industry.
Employing cutting-edge technology,
many of the world's best minds are
creating products that bedazzle
and engage players of all ages in
everything from killing bad guys,
to performing life-saving surgeries.
>>Man: If we tilt the skull
down a little bit we can
see these others, here's...
>>Douglas: There's little doubt in
anyone's mind that putting the people
into an environment where they can
experience the things that they need
to learn, they can make mistakes
without risk, they
can try new things.
The engagement that comes from that
type of environment is a better way
to learn than just
sitting them in a classroom
and just throwing information
at them.
>>Narrator: Clients such as the
U.S. Military spend millions
to train personnel in
simulated environments
like this virtual residency
called Pulse.
>>Douglas: The first
version of Pulse was built
to model Bethesda Naval
Medical Intensive Care Unit.
You work with other care
givers, doctors and nurses,
and you can see the things that you
would be seeing in the real world.
You can shine the light
on the pupil and based
on the physiological
condition of that patient,
the eye will dilate appropriately.
You can check their ears, touch
them, feel them, listen to them
in the virtual world so that
you can do the diagnosis
and that's what we want to
replicate is the real experience
that the doctor or nurse
would have in the real world.
>>Narrator: These days
engaging simulations
and games can be found just about
anywhere critical thinking happens.
Anywhere, that is,
except the classroom.
>>Teacher: X over 360.
>>Kurt: Our schools are in
trouble if our response to things
like cellphones and new
technology is to ban them,
is to say "Well you can't
bring that into school."
And games I think really
are the cutting edge
because they probably more
than anything are good
at letting people start as
novices and become experts.
>>Student: See?
>>Student: Oh yeah.
>>David: We don't live in an
industrial economy anymore.
We live in a knowledge economy and
so we have to think about education
in a fundamentally different way.
We can't be focusing on
basic facts and basic skills.
We have to think about ways
of thinking that are going
to matter more than what we do
in traditional schools right now.
>>Kurt: On the Wii we
can do some of that.
>>Narrator: Kurt Squire and
David Williamson Shaffer research
educational games at the
University of Wisconsin.
In one study Squire gauged the impact
of the game Civilization on a group
of fourth, fifth, and sixth graders.
>>Kurt: A lot of the kids
come in hating school
and in particular really
hating social studies.
And we start them off just
playing the game for fun,
seeing if they can't get
involved in the game.
It's really quite complex.
There's a lot of historical
vocabulary,
a lot of maps, a lot of terminology.
They start to think about the
model as a simulation of history
that they can think with.
So they start thinking
about how does technology
and geography influence the way
civilizations grow and fade?
From there we find they usually start
producing their own games and all
of them now that we work with
have gone to straight "A"s
in social studies and other areas.
And these are 10 and
11 year old kids.
If you look at one of the
biggest crisis right now
in schools it's underachieving
boys who become labeled A.D.H.D.
and then they're starting on the
social problems, fighting and so on.
And teachers are really running and
"What do we do with these kids?"
And we think games is a
really powerful way to tap
into their interests and channel
it towards something that's
more positive.
The kids certainly love it.
>>Teacher: It's already 9:50.
We've got two hours
to work on this exam.
What I want you to try
to do is do a 3D version
of a Donkey Kong animation.
>>Narrator: McKinley
Technology High School
in Washington D.C. has embraced
the brave new virtual world.
>>Teacher: Any questions?
>>Narrator: Plagued by
declining enrollment
and campus violence the
school was shut down in 1997
and reopened six years later as a
tech magnet with the latest hardware
and a revamped curriculum focusing
on biotechnology and digital media.
>>Teacher: And then you're actually
controlling the camera, that's good.
Switch it so you're
looking through that camera.
>>Daniel: We want our
students not to be consumers
of simulation technology, but
designers of simulation technology
where they are determining the
structure of how that story is told.
For that is where one is able to
be creative and personalize it.
>>Student: You need to
move our your camera.
>>Student: I'm saying it's locked.
>>Student: But you still
need to move your camera.
>>Daniel: By enabling them
to have the technical skills,
they're able to express
individualization
and creative skills.
>>Ciarra: Basically what I did was
I made the stadium and the stage
and all the chairs and everything.
Even though you see there's a
whole bunch of chairs around,
it actually didn't take
that long at all to do.
That was actually the easiest part.
>>Daniel: By bringing the students
and the technologies together,
we are able to insure that the kids
see connections beyond just the
standard written text or the math
problem, to see why math feeds
into videogame design, how algebra,
physics, and geometry are part
of what must be considered when
trying to design an engaging
and interactive experience.
>>Student: So basically this is the
American Red Cross Fire Safety game
that a couple of students at McKinley
and myself created during the summer.
We spent six weeks doing it.
There's three to four different
rooms because we have the bedroom,
the bathroom, and the family room.
The purpose of the
game is to go through
and assess all of the fire hazards.
And what happens when you see a
hazard, you have to click on it
and then it zooms in and it
gives you a little excerpt
about the fire hazard like "Don't
overload plugs" and things like that.
>>Ciarra: Just the energy
of McKinley is so different.
It makes you want to learn.
They teach us programming and
animation and 3D modeling and Maya
and things like that and
that's really exciting.
>>Narrator: McKinley students
are also asked to test games
and simulations like this virtual lab
developed and distributed for free
by the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute.
>>Dennis: There is no question that
some of our virtual labs for example,
the Bacterial I.D. lab which
involves obtaining D.N.A. sequence,
using that to identify
an unknown microbe.
That's the kind of
experiment that is hard to do
in most high school settings
so it does allow some teachers
to expose students to things
that they wouldn't be
able to do otherwise.
The other thing that
animation and media is good
for is revealing the hidden worlds
that simply aren't tangible to people
in any other way and you can tell
people it's exciting and interesting,
but it's always better
to just show them.
>>Eitan: And this is actually how
your body deals with some sort
of bacterial infection, how
it clears it out, you know,
minus the really cool graphics.
>>Narrator: Another game McKinley
students helped incubate is Immune
Attack, a multimillion
dollar project underwritten
by the Federation of
American Scientists.
>>Eitan: In the game you have
to reactivate somebody's defunct
immune system and teach them how
to cope with bacterial
and viral infections.
>>Student: That's the macrophage?
>>Etian: Yep, that's the
macrophage right there.
>>Every month or so we have a new
build that we're very interested
in getting feedback from
students how does this work?
What's complicated about this?
What's clear?
How can we improve the game?
And more recently we've taken on
two McKinley high school seniors
as interns at FAS and
they're actually helping
to develop the game now so it's
been a very mutually beneficial
relationship working with
McKinley High School.
>>Narrator: Whether they are
debugging simulations for scientists
or test driving the
latest commercial games,
kids seem hard-wired to the task.
And with a little guidance they
can become expert designers.
>>Eric: What should these guys do?
>>Ben: Again, knock you
back, but then roll over you.
>>Eric: Okay.
>>Narrator: When he
was 9 cancer patient,
Ben Duskin approached the Make-A-Wish
Foundation with an unusual request.
>>Eric: His wish was
to make a video game
where the player fights cancer
cells so that he could send it back
to the kids who were still
in the treatment center.
This was just after he
had finished his chemo.
And Ben was in a position to
know uniquely what would help
and his primary motive was
to distract and entertain.
>>Narrator: Enlisting the
aid of Software Engineer,
Eric Johnston Ben designed a game
that is engaging and enlightening.
>>Eric: One of the things that was I
think a fantastic idea of Ben's was
to take the side effects, not
the cancer cells themselves,
but the side effects are
represented in the game
as the monsters, a
monster for each one.
So there's a giant chicken for
chicken pox, and there's a robot
that flings barf at you
that's the vomit monster.
By making those monsters
large and then
as you attack them they grow smaller
and smaller and less scary was a part
of making the game engaging.
>>Right, so now we've got
billiard balls shooting at us.
>>For parents and siblings it
really provided a look into how
from the kids' point of view,
how the treatment process looks.
>>Ben: Whoa!
>>Eric: Oh yeah, I added that.
>>David: We have technologies that
can help kids learn in new ways
and we can essentially build
models of what an education
for the future might look like.
And my hope in doing that
is that parents and teachers
and school board members, and
kids, and politicians and all
of us will look at what happens in
these environments and say "Wow,
why can't school be more like that?"
>>Teacher: You're going to have
three choices for what you want
to work on during this class.
>>Narrator: Seeing their potential
to transform public education,
the Federation of American
Scientists has called
for a major federal effort
to fund serious games.
>>Henry: The potential
here is so huge
that it just seems a national
shame that we're not putting money
on the table to find
out if this is right.
I mean the payoff is spectacular.
You have to think about
using this technology
that could actually completely
transform productivity in education
and get people who are otherwise
be uninterested or underserved
by this system fully engaged,
and we just can't afford
to leave anybody behind.
>>Student: Land, that's
like geography.
>>Student: That's geography.
>>Douglas: I think the advances
in technology these days are going
to allow the gaming and simulation
community to create simulations
of anything, and when we can deploy
that over the Internet
we will then have
on every desktop the best teacher in
the world available to every student.
>>Kurt: Good games are really
compelling for their players
to the point that people are
worried about addiction and things.
And you know it's ironic, can
you imagine is there a world
in which we'd have
addiction to school?
You know, someone would walk
in and say "I'm addicted
to learning, I need more."
>>Students: Whoo!
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.